hello and happy Thursday Rob's actually
not here let's just get rid of that name
boom he's gone it's just me Eric
sorry for the delay there I had to
change some settings because the game
was in full screen yet because we just
downloaded this morning we're planning
dying lights bad blood which is
basically their version of battle royale
except with the twist because it's PvE
and PvP I believe it's 12 go in one
comes out I've got to move this picture
in picture probably to at some point but
let me show you the game real quick here
we are you can customize your character
you know I could be an athlete to be an
engineer then you can be an agent which
is coming soon
let's be an athlete oh I'm change your
masks oh look at this
you can I got the golden founder I have
so we're given a code by Techland so
we're able to get this founders addition
to use wow so many weapons
anyways I haven't played die lay in a
long time but I feel like dying light
was a very like well underrated going
into it let's give it a go do you want
to toriel casual normal or rank there's
no all right let's do casual for now
it's my first game you know it's been a
while find a weapons got a harvest
samples and then you evacuate okay
is it free I don't believe the early
access is free I think as some people
mentioned you have to get the founders
pack to play but you guys can double
check me on that one there's full
players how we started now waiting for
more players holy smokes this feels
really fast come on fists oh yeah you
could hold down your melees that's right
parkour that's my core I played on Xbox
one the first time I played by the way
so this will be a little bit of a
learning experience yeah okay all right
so we do have a stamina bar for attack
at least is it the same mechanics and
dining light because it was good it
seems that way so far crime crime
honestly kind of figure out how to play
oh it's C for couch alright I get that
slide action they'll never expect the
old slide hop smash and there's a lot of
a wrench
oh the sledgehammer you still do that
like spinning attack or was that just
because I had the skill there's no
inventory hey this is a cool game says
Josh can break yeah I heard um Lucy had
a lot of fun with it a couple times
she's played it she's actually the one
who kind of informed me that this was
gonna be in early access today we're
waiting for more players hold F to start
match-making okay oh I had to do that
whoops hold to have to start game
joining the game alright let's do it my
bad guys I thought it was matchmaking
the whole time
oh let's go bring it on random strangers
thank you guys all for tuning in let's a
shadow play this in case we somehow like
that call of duty stream if we somehow
managed to get a victory or something
the first game you never know but thank
you guys all for tuning in GameSpot live
we go live Monday to Friday 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time unless there's a
holiday oh look at that a scythe and a
landmine and a Molly okay so you have
equipment - no idea how to use that
stuff yet at least
let's find some zombies or something huh
maybe Sarah map
map was not M or tab okay that's not
what I wanted the old running was shifts
but then holding tab because you want to
look a whole I technically want to look
at the map but I can you would be able
to loot those bags in dying light why
let me loot you I'm not sure you're
gonna have opponent I don't know I saw
some I saw some opponents queue up in
the lobby unless they were like BOTS or
something flash hazardous whatever bring
it watches on B's get your head chopped
off oh oh okay good fun fact
right-click is the equipment and I just
placed the landline down in hey myself
so we're learning the hard way I'd like
to sleep this is normally where I would
sleep can you not loot that okay
all right good to know good to know
sorry we took a lot of damage it's
alright first game learning I'm gonna
find I like first lead upgrade shock
upgrade Mali so I guess you could craft
to technically well hangar name I got
rid of one where molotovs
type painkillers I love to eat some
painkillers hold the right mouse button
to use medkit that's my Molotov I was
lied to
someone lied to me and said hold right
mouse button to heal when it says it's
clearly my Molotov oh there's a tanker
that's not so good that's not good at
all I didn't mean it
oh crap I just
hai-yah medicine
you had medicine Oh so I put the
electricity on my okay so if you
right-click a mod ah when you have a
weapon equipped it'll like modify it I'm
just pretty nice do we fight the tanker
I really want to you but here I go
or this art demolisher
where'd he go I hear is ass oh not cool
burn this just looks like the first game
yeah but we're fighting other people
potentially
oh he's still alive
leerin is - now get Grenada oh he has so
much okay the Molotov is did nothing to
him we're out of here
we're out of here no thank you I need
help
chat how do I access my my my map I
really need some ooh food food food
Oh just Auto ate the food okay had a
burger sounds good for lunch actually
burger Oh parkour oh is that like a gold
bow yeah
Oh like a baseball bat action here a
better baseball bat where where our
opponents we need to go wreck some shop
or something hit a home run game says
you hard for something
alt f4 yeah that's definitely it mmm oh
that guy doesn't look very nice right
here you know he'd run where did bro go
know some guy left the session dude we
had shot that guy oh my bleeding oh no
all right he died - we got him - we got
him - we should have killed him though I
don't know why my guy stopped swinging
damn it we could have killed that guy
for sure all right back to the main menu
it's okay we got we got an F
what's up a key game there's your
shoutout zombie twin Johnson can you
smell the rock is cooking uh how's the
picture and picture for everyone it's
all right I hope I can move it - all
right so it says hold F to start
matchmaking hold an F it's not doing
anything we'll just give it a second
Cope's lost my chat we definitely need a
chat right oh my god you missed him he
ran to the right and he missed yeah but
like that I I guess once I was bleeding
it it told me I couldn't attack anymore
and I had to hold G to stop or something
or like maybe bleeding causes you to
stop being able to attack for a second
so maybe bleed is really good I shoot it
through the Molotov I don't sooner or we
should have backpedaled off of him and
shot the other boat or arrow that I had
known I mean know what I mean we're
learning we're learning when does that
Bell come to console that I don't know
yeah we're playing dying lights like
battle royale their take on it
it's a PVE pvp there's 12 players
that'll go in hopefully 12 I don't know
if there's 12 last game there's
definitely players in the last game
though you can craft if you find parts
we're made we were able to make an
electric dagger my guess is you're
supposed to kill those bigger guys to
like get stuff from them so yeah my safe
area
oh yeah the run back mechanic they'll
look back mechanic you can run and hold
F or ya to look back dude this was a
trip eeeh swim those uh nighttime
zombies would show up forget their name
ready but those guys were scary
oh that's Z list Fox oak oh I wonder if
that's Co carnage
maybe another streamer maybe we can hunt
that stream where guys we're the other
players hurt well we just actually
fought one and died two one but we also
got him so you know at least at least he
didn't get that - smell that victory
read the loading screen instructions I'm
going to - hold up I was holding up
trust me I was holding up the game spot
okay black out yes we played it Monday
and Tuesday Sheldon there's actually a
new mode today
I think it's called close a wild guy
shield close quarters and I think it's
all SMG pistol and shotguns
no assault rifles which means everyone
SMG but we checked it out those two days
and I think community Friday's tomorrow
which is with Ben and John Luke they're
gonna check it out as well so stay tuned
to that I got ok that's how you extract
got it
I'm at a calm I am a stamina get
shielded from so we okay so this is what
we have to do is extract these now we're
level two okay all right we are learned
oh there's the Hulk see up so that's how
you level up you got to get extract the
sample so now we have ten more health
which is good let's continue to loot it
up no can't get in
Oh throwing axes steel blade upgrade we
found the dagger I need to figure out
how to to access those other items how
do I access my throwing daggers just
happen all right hold on does anyone
know how to access my left hand side
that's what we need to figure out
because right now right right right
click definitely brings up the shield
but I don't know how to cycle through
those items sadly because I would love
to do some upgrades right now so yeah
that could be another tactic is to oh
all right let's take the painkillers why
not shield back
oh we should be going to get those
samples though huh I'll go try to get a
sample here that's supposed to be sample
here oh but it's a big hive and I don't
wanna mess with those guys let's try all
those axes bye bye so they're supposed
to be something here f1 f2 f3 for the
left side thank you so much I appreciate
that I cooked it too long I'm an idiot
it's fine it's fine fine whatever
never get told we finding some health
huh
somehow we need some health
which a chest come on give me some help
yeah painkillers that didn't help me
get light back though
or painkillers
or does it thank you for the shout oh
yeah it does okay let's take those
[Applause]
really oh hello
should be interesting
oh god it hurts okay
okay sir I'm trying to deal with this
big old dude oh we're in trouble all
right we need more painkillers we'll
come back to that Wilco we'll come back
to that oh you would think these guys
would drop some stuff not so much though
okay this is not good guys oh we can
level up we can level up come on come on
come on level up
yes okay that's that's like the pro tip
I guess is just go find samples so that
you can level up with them
how is it still hitting oh there's
another guy slice and dice some cheese
oh we're clicking like you bait them so
that we can like quickly get the sample
oh he's not having it you like this
guy's you like this
get him all there's two of them that's
cheating I killed the other guy get out
of here
no no I think he's following me he's a
hundred percent following me make it
make it make it I dare you I dare you
dare you come on a refrigerator give me
a burger never know I'll never know
we're here
I need health so bad level did that guy
like take my thing cuz I feel like we
almost had that goood and killed and on
top of that I feel like he's wearing the
track bags
it is tough this is tough
you're allowed to team yeah well I I
don't want to get I don't want them to
team kill me clearly they were they were
both after me and all I wanted to do was
get my own extract I was working so hard
for it you know I can do that I should
have been doing that yeah I forgot
forgot forgot forgot about those pro
strats those um those look back shots
and less employ them more shoot our only
me and Co are level three okay some
other guy was killed code just killed
him so it's just me and kono or at least
that level huh damn someone already farm
that one really need HP I think
someone's must have smaller over here
and looted everything
perhaps
come on some bread anything oh I got
wardrobe Thank You lers sir
yeah I need to level up
leveling up would help ko is level four
now which is obviously a problem I'll
say it's a little cumbersome the buttons
over just have that on f4 or whatever
okay not okay so we do have a bleed
weapon down
slice and dice okay so they're they're
poisoning me but we should maybe level
no it's white it's too little
right after all that all those
painkillers we just got and mucked it up
I need a burger
oh I see fire over here
good knowing you
Boise I was yet with yeah with yeah
nothing any painkillers all right all
right let's go let's go let's go papa
Minnie I wish I could pop a mini slappy
oh yeah that's how you do it you level
up what is this guy huh
oh he's got 50x samples was that Oh
oh he's got a gun Oh get out of here
with that sir Co carnage you need to not
be using a gun oh we got streamer killed
shucks
oh he had shield too dude he had a gun
all right so I guess when you hit level
5 you get hunted good on him
all right on to the next game on to the
next game we tried it's pretty fun
though any rewards
no no rewards there's there's boots and
stuff you can get though uh is their
story around the battle royale mode No
so it's a water match now stand-alones
went off his correct sound solid
searching for games why do you kill poor
zombies didn't they suffer enough now
walking dead man
dude I don't want to be converted
alright so I gotta figure out how to get
shields I wonder if that's also I have
not seen a gun so I have no idea where
he got a gun from but somehow the gun
didn't do that much damage shockingly
all right there's med kits that's good
to know I should be looking for those
more often red box red box okay old cap
to start game alright let's go
I want revenge ko you're lucky I had a
gun I might play this in a minute says
Diamond 9000 nice
what are your pc specs says doctor
fabulous I 787 100k a 1070 32 gigs of
ram that's mostly what you need to know
is it running well yeah it's running
well I haven't had any like hitches or
anything it's been good for me I got a
shield I didn't see anyone join did you
guys why not have anyone in this game
but well will still try to you know see
what we can
still got that awesome park horn small
house okay okay what just happened that
was really weird I don't know what
happened I was literally just spamming
my mouse button early-access don't worry
the thing
I wish I had this game hope for ps4 ah
you never know it could be something
down the road daggers and stuff
we should probably that up for the
future some arrows let's get to our next
five thing to try to take out
we got down here alright another small
hi oh you okay with that though it
seemed like someone shot her oh oh
stay down should get my shield all right
we didn't level from that which is it
was a small hive so oh yeah we want to
Oh any angular's we're sure
bleed okay
Oh
it's another small one
level up
get that light back with important
I'm still not sure if anyone's actually
in this game I think it's just me
so if anything happens I guess it's on
me
[Music]
good knowing you guys oh hello super one
special oh we got wrench arrows is good
nothing else okay where's the
it's a small hive
it's just you yeah but you can train
yeah we're training we're training for
the next match well we'll get sweet
revenge what I need to figure out is how
the hell to get weapons see if we can
find a larger hive or something doesn't
look that exciting says animus well I
mean I think there's more tension when
there's actually other players in the
game you know you can choose to help
each other or kill each other which is
what I did okay how many players in a
match you can have up to 12 if we
actually you know
we're able to get what does that have
[Applause]
what oh I threw that you guys want me to
leave the match so we can find the match
with people on it I'm down to do that
it's not a big deal
right is a goon here
- and now ahead
alright bye is that
what excuse me
all right ooh a helmet oh that's how you
get armor okay you get a helmet from
these guys
that's good to know dude the arrow does
quite a bit of damage
it would appear oh wait the sample duh
find a real match okay sure killed
people is it a good game um I like dying
light le max oh it's fun to me
playing with nunn yeah right now it was
playing with nothing so I'll get in the
game make sure people queue with us this
time find a match with nobody in it that
was a match with nobody in it right
there oh really was it actually a UH was
it actually a bad blood add Sam that's
funny alright so we're searching for
players
I'll let the player counter build up
maybe and see if that does it and then
we'll hold tab start the match
oh yeah you're watching GameSpot live
where we go live everyone in Friday
11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
playing some dining lights bad blood
which is their take on the Battle Royale
genre but with a twist so as you saw we
still PvE against zombies you're trying
to level up your character seems like
once you hit level 5 you get hunted I'm
not exactly sure what that does yet but
definitely interested to see what that
does
hatches searching for games nobody yet
we had a game earlier
yeah it's in early access not a DLC this
is a standalone thing II should do the
old like there there 360 no-scope
there might not be any players because
you have to play normal alright we'll go
to normal there were players earlier in
casual but I'll play normal that's fine
casual is just custom game oh how did oh
so people join my game earlier is that
what it was cuz I definitely had players
in my game earlier so thanks for the
tips appreciate it oh yeah okay so now
we're searching just straight up for
games
verifying match for me game joining game
joining players alright sounds good
is the format for is this the full
original nice flick now was even close
yeah I do I do like this I gotta I gotta
remember to do this if someone is
chasing me so that you know it's
information obviously
I've got three players at least four or
five okay codes in this one oh we're
gonna get sweet revenge Oh sack reels in
this game oh we got streamers in this
game boys
we've got streamers wait already dead
I hear people fighting oh we come in
after them boys
they were teaming since you're in casual
okay well now they're gonna die
oh here you go here's the Mack oh he's
got a gun fight you with my hands I mean
my pipe
all right try to team up with someone no
they're all gonna die work that ranch
you got it all right so now we're
playing for real but that's why they are
teaming Oh gotcha okay that's
interesting there's other keys to change
your weapons not just one two three four
looks like is this multiplayer yes it's
up to 12 players in a match
now we are cooking with gas landmine we
should like try to bait someone huh very
small hive to hive back here I try to
get the level 2 here
hey what I'm right on it how is it in
here
feel like there's so many mall togs we
just burn one or two then you guys watch
Walking Dead hey you said they would use
the fire as bait to like get them away
as mentioned there's a Molotov all right
so you level up all right there's a
bunch of people level two already will
be about level two here in a second
airdrop if you need guns all right good
to know crime thank you really hope you
weapons go to the air drops okay we
gotta go to the air drops we need their
jobs thank you guys thank you for your
tips appreciate it
let's just try to keep loved one I guess
oh it's a spitter okay we got armor from
that was every game copying for tonight
this isn't copying for necessarily
alright level three it's good okay so
someone just took one out there I don't
know if we can squabble yet Oh two
people just died some guy named
fortnight monopoly just kill them
Wow porn a monopoly was killed dude a
bunch of people are dying I'll make it
yeah everyone's just dying meanwhile
we're just having ourselves a time here
oh no do we care get out of here another
spot oh he's fighting someone oh we can
roll up on him we can roll up on him
oh my god cut back her revenge oh how
did that hit me oh he hit me with his
thing I was like dude did he just oh no
no no we gotta make it oh you can't
GG do you see what I was trying to do
though I was trying to I tried to put
the landmine so that he would run into
it and I think he threw a Molotov at me
alright alright oh that was not bad I
guess he saw me because I think he was
going after the goon yeah alright still
learning
I thought we had a good plan there like
drop the landmine watch him run into it
I should have serpentine this is a game
where I feel like it would be nice to
like be able to get like those left side
stuff like are not different
I should like buying those to something
else because I'm really like it's really
hard to for me to go to F 1 2 F 4 while
trying to run and like navigating that
so whereas like with the left stuff I
couldn't easily mousewheel that stuff
that won't wanted to or if you like I
think VB deal also work later
good knowing you you can teabag you know
granddaddy cush his coach Remus typing
touted Jeff X Co is a big co carnage is
a pretty big streamer so it's probably
just playing the game I like the
landmine tactic I don't know if it
worked though I can't tell if it blew
blew up on both of us to be honest
because I took a bunch of like took a
bunch of like explosion damage alright
let's try to find some stuff because we
got a thing here by 5 right here
oh this one harity oh no I'm dead hello
I won't kill them
Oh gotcha gotcha get out of here my
dagger is too quick for you sir all we
need we need to get some health or
something or hope that this got cleared
so that we can inform it all right whoa
come on are we good we good we good we
level two we level two we escaped that
one guy I don't know how he probably ran
into another player I think is what
happened like so the guy I killed
probably killed the guy that was chasing
me which obviously is very fortuitous
for us as we were able to finish off the
other guy like fortunately
that well we got an icicle to the Icicle
I'm sorry guys a burger do we just come
back for that later
let me bring it with us nope
should I save that it's definitely a
mistake in my part
dude everyone's dying lko that guy was
in our last game he died again how do
the sewers they come wow they got dodge
moves
capoeira so the harder the tier two's or
the the medium hive samples they
definitely have the you get like armor
from that well it depends on what you
fight I guess but you can potentially
get armor from them
just upgrading my stuff just to clear
out the inventory a bit
we got another hive here somewhere
you realize that parkour is a big dude
all right let's uh
thank you
oh there's a Deuter up there where did
the airdrop go oh I should have paid
attention to that
I just lit myself on fire
like this the goons got a lot of life oh
it's a big high of no wonder does it
drop near by it I see red
oh the drops right there
oh [ __ ] there's like dudes there
oh my gosh that guy just got destroyed
got a handgun a German something got a
DIY shields oh I just wanted to medkit I
also used all of our bullets and he
didn't die good
got an out par quorum never wash those
parkour races
No
died
very dude go
so why didn't it pick up the DIY sheet
whatever it's fine
we lived that's all that matters
question is do we fight that goon or not
at level 2 I really wish we had some
grenades molotovs that gun did like no
damage to him by the way I don't know if
you guys saw that but I was doing
absolutely no damage to him and by him I
mean the oh god damn it
this is the goon we were dealing with
earlier we're just gonna try to come
home oh god oh you know what
surprisingly oh is it because I darlin
[Music]
oh I'm okay with this brute force it it
you'll be fine because I think in theory
we should level up from extracting this
there's one guy that's level four gun
works if you hit the tart did I not hit
him I like point-blank hit fired him and
it should it should have worked
in theory now clearly I must have missed
oh no I did pro plays into the sad plays
oh shoot there's a there's a guy that I
can't deal with the bloater or the
whatever the guy that shoots range is
called that kill him first the range guy
got again that this truck
Oh someone just shot me with an arrow
don't know from where there's no way a
zombie has an arrow though you know
oh yeah burger so we need
where'd you where did you
shoot that GD arrow from sir
you trying to be Legolas huh
someone's playing like possum baiting
this goon for me to try to kill while he
tries to snipe me ain't doing all the
work for him
Oh behind me
stamina he's actually using a shield
properly you don't know about my parkour
skills though
fudge I try to throw some axes at him
dang it he's smart he's smart in the use
of his shield GG I think um I think it
maybe if you have like a bigger weapon
oh wow that's some phat progression
right there
we got a normal loot crate that we can
open see what we get
I choose my reward do I want a pink mask
sure I'll take a pink mask all right
mmm that's not good it'll come back
right it's currently in early access F F
mu I think I'm stuck though all right
hold on let me close the game and reopen
the game early access guys early access
yeah I'm not sure what I could have did
against that one guy nice play and it
wasn't that good play I just wanted to
throw axes I don't what's up didn't do
thanks for watching I'm doing pretty
well how are you it's been like a battle
royale week for sure
this is dying light from tech land
whoops all right and back into the game
we go
oh do you guys want that mask should we
put on that pink mask
really just stand out
all right let's go get into another
match is it open early access I think
some people are saying that you have to
buy like a founders pack or something
like that
yeah if you if you want to it's on Steam
early access it's 1999 and you get the
mask and three weapon skins and a
thousand blood books that's currently
how it is
so your dream came true to make a theme
of the week for the stream not
necessarily good know how I kicked I
kicked earlier who is this like a Oh II
used to kick get off me I said get off
me it will be free don't worry Zeus yeah
probably
except just Jordan stream says MMX it
Clara thei what's up so Johnny light is
getting battle royale interesting any
good so far I think it's pretty fun
grant I'm still learning all of like I
wouldn't say all but mechanics and
things like that and getting used to you
know dealing with other players while
also dealing with the zombies I had a
gun and I missed everything play fifa
battle royale says uncle Pete Hines at
some point FIFA 19 demo is actually out
today if you guys want to check that out
I'll try to do a better job of finding
the buh-buh-buh and it shield all right
the trying to find the drop so that we
can try to get a gun again so the
interesting about the guns is that there
isn't that many bullets in the gun
there's white like what for something
like that which seems pretty fair the
goal is to level up and probably the
last ones standing I would imagine or
you're trying to at least get stuff out
I haven't gotten to that end game yet I
haven't hit level 5 so we try to get
there the highest level I've gotten to
is 4 before then getting killed it does
seem like you do
gain some type of like experience or
whatnot when you do kill another player
though
[Applause]
didn't know you had feelings there okay
can't kick lookouts no it's okay we're
gonna level from this I'll be
interesting to see if this is like a
part of like part of dynamite to at all
like I was like oh yeah upgrade to a
bleeding bow sure let's try to find
another hive here Oh someone did one
over there huh might be trying to do
this
Wow how does that wish have a good name
bad
dang that guy was still alive how people
are dying off here playing the PvE game
you know
Oh
they mean that oh my god can we start a
streaming fail moment clip thing I just
cooked the grenade and killed myself to
get my bow and arrow he's gonna Legolas
him she just threw the grenade and then
like shot at him though so stupid it's
so stupid on so many levels
what's up the kid I apologize to the
stream you thought that my 10 snipe
shots in a cod blackout was bad I think
that was worse
this guy dumb or something yeah
apparently Austin I keep forgetting it
cooks does that's pretty bad
Mario game over Sam yep pretty much it's
alright I'll make up for it it's
interesting that you can actually die in
the lobby what's the point of that
haha that was funny I meant it I meant
to do that
everyone I meant to do it does he race
it from your memory it never happens
slam with JAMA I don't have that I'm
pretty sure this would work right okay
here we go here we go here we go
there's no time to waste be on the move
so final weapon is harvest ampoules
evacuate you probably it's probably like
one of those things were like you're
when you're level five and you get
hunted that's when you probably want to
evacuate and/or kill said person that's
level five that would make some sense to
me all right we got throwing axes
nearest hi how did I take damage already
what the hell did the game like carry my
damage from the lobby over because
that's um
oh there's someone over here that's why
that thing chased him oh no it's just a
zombie okay
they're saying he can duck my pack hit
by like something else is totally crap
oh yeah I am I told him okay I was like
dude there's no way this is a zombie all
right I gotta be I got to be more
careful I'm doing some stupid some
stupid stuff there
I don't think so King mister afro not
really big goof in the chat yeah yeah
big goof
oh my god I'm done sorry dead Joe sorry
disappointed you
[Music]
man full swing slowly guys like that oh
there's a gun
which a medkit no bullets you might have
got me once there look who it is it's
mr. ko middle mouse button like that
middle mouse button is your aim down
sight but I guess it has to be because
right click is like the left side items
there's 12 of us let's go
try attack try jump attacking for
tonight alright it never happened the
good anything I never happened what do
you what do we even talk about well
goodnight thing it's weird
grenades didn't even know that was part
of the game alright
a little secret underground basement oh
you just start off with $75
oh there's a strange guy up top this is
bad this is bad news bears Co was killed
that was pretty cool actually
that alone was worth it to get that like
aerial stabbed on
tinker dude or hmm big guy that ain't
nothing I can deal with yet
someone says he's part of the pay's clan
that's cool you know Teague
[Music]
yeah I wouldn't be happy neither oh I
just lived myself on fire dude that is
like not hurting him oh of course he's
got the range to hit me
well I didn't hurt him either how do we
look that other one so fast earlier okay
clearly I'm not tactically maneuvering
around this guy I know that are I was
level three last time I've fallen or
something as I remember earlier one pot
of goon we're not as in bad shape is
that that seemed pretty bad oh is that a
what's the blue is that a drop probably
I died but we can go investigate
oh but always blue where those guys were
like that I fought earlier
that does not give you very much that's
why you need med kids
seriously how are you not dead
Thank You w-2 gamer with some kissies Oh
No
like it - there's people that are level
four do we waste the bullets on that guy
I don't think so right I need a level
three somehow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you can't measure the shotgun it's a
hunting chocolate I can very mess with
it
as the red indicate other players or is
that jizz omni's sorry oh there's a play
right there Oh God oh I didn't
middle mouse is so awkward is he
fighting the dude yeah yeah this is army
dude did you see how that did like no
damn it even though we hit him in like
the head oh oh are you teaming are you
teaming bro oh you're so teaming alright
thank the heavens that that worked oh
that was stressful
yeah a level-3 me baby we have no ammo
or you King how does this guy not have
ammo
I don't know how we're gonna kill that
other guy though I wonder if he even
finished it
where were we just now it was definitely
a level 4 guy that was fighting a goon
here yeah he killed it dude what I don't
get is that first shot gunshot maybe
because it's a shotgun and it doesn't
have that much range but that first shot
I took on that other guy that was
fighting the goon like that guy shoulda
took way more damage all right so I
think the red on the radar is a person
though like when you see someone on your
mini-map and it's red it's a person see
close no arranged Mis yeah well he
almost killed me
[Music]
nothing to deal with these guys
helicopter has arrived only one can
board I get to that helicopter I guess
ooh [ __ ] is booking it out of here
parkour
our core
or core
what
this guy's coming up I don't think can
kill him but but where did his little
thing go
I can't board the helicopter
oh you had a gun okay so you can only
evacuate if you're the level five and
good job Kristy see
he had a gun
about the combat shotgun there we might
have been able to win if I was able to
just hold the hold the gun till the end
but I would have died to the other guy
so we definitely had to use the gun on
that guy so we just we got to find a way
to level up fast everything yeah I know
look at the text at the top yeah yeah I
know I saw after the fact I wonder if he
can just run away or if he has to kill
me I wonder if you if you if you have
the love like if you're at level 5 and
you're being hunted I wonder if you can
just straight up run to the extraction
zone and then that's it or if you
actually have to like you know beat the
other player like could he have just
avoided me and like not even bothered
how many people in the match 12 dang
yeah I wasn't really in a good position
to win that play given that he
definitely had a gun to because Emma was
pretty sparse so when I pick up that
shotgun I got three bullets of which I
used the one on him earlier before he he
at level five and then I used to to kill
that other guy that was chasing me you
should have kept the shotgun I did have
the shotgun it just didn't have any ammo
I used those last two bullets to kill
that one guy that was chasing me if I
didn't kill that guy would have died
even before we got to that point so it's
kind of a moot point there's only way
our last match though appreciate
everyone tuning and hopefully we can
find a way to end on a high note
unless we die really fast then we might
play one more but my guess is should be
okay unless
it's a fun match though okay left the
session no weapons huh
still no weapons people hopefully this
isn't making you guys sick or anything
apologies
[Applause]
[Applause]
should be okay because this usually
levels you too and get your life back
did I handle that sloppily yes I
definitely let's just focus on leveling
and then trying to get to the drops when
we can
definitely someone here
kill them with my molotov oh no oh I'm
dead dude all right we're gonna play one
more
that was weird um maybe because of the
fire damage cuz I popped the second
painkiller and it didn't do anything for
me so why would you not tell me to go in
the lock whatever also what are the
point of the hives it's to level up and
to heal so you want to level up to five
because you have to get to five to then
be able to evacuate as it says there and
so yeah that's the purpose of the hives
it's the level up is to level up to gain
damage to gain life also just so that
you can get to low five so that you can
evacuate any depth in the melee combat I
mean kind of because you can get shields
so you know like the smarter players
were worse like you know you can't just
spam necessarily and you can technically
you know charge up your weapon I also
think attacking from like above if you
can get a jump attack like especially on
the zombies there's like you know like
insta kills you might be able to do more
damage also to a player perhaps from
from above
currently vennett it's $20 for early
access but
you can't swing in here buddy
back off fruit Oh angel that's his back
what's so curious like how effective
like you actually take the player should
probably get myself killed in case
there's a weird bug actually there what
are your thoughts and opinions on this
game as Ethan Perkins um so far it's
kind of funny I like returning to
Dynalite because I had a lot of fun
playing the original dying light as a
battle royale I think it's fine
I mean it's it's got all the things that
you would expect except like I said
you're you're also dealing with the
zombies and leveling up that way the
guns are pretty pretty sparse so it's
not like everyone has a gun and you only
have limited ammo so you know there's
more emphasis on getting those drops
obviously but I would say also um you
know the grenades and stuff seem pretty
strong all right let's try again
last one for serious
throwing axes
you like someone's behind me somewhere
so you get armor from some guys like
that guy we try to show you the exact
execution so technically if I wanted to
I could like see that all day but these
guys are a little fine
do you have breath of the wild I mean
yes I beat it there's people around me
like two people
someone's here oh he's up top walking
okay there's definitely more tactics
than as you saw there because he blocked
me oh he had a freaking things Hey
he had a painkiller or something I just
spammed it on him because I think sickle
is faster do you really have anything
though
oh boy we are in a pickle now now that
we had to deal with that guy
if we can find a medkit nope just a
sickle
someone else is here to die here
holy here somewhere
there's a thing either
that's a weird do you see like gray
arrow on the top right like this
spinning in a circle can open this
fridge oh hey if we swung again we might
actually had a chance he's still
bleeding ah damn
alright well
and win them all I don't know why it's
not letting me anyways how does it run
and what are your specs the specs where
I 780 700 K it's got a gtx 1070 32 gigs
of ram it runs well I didn't have any
hitches or any problems there if you
want to check it out 1999 currently for
the founders pack I think you get like
three masks or no I'm asking 3 weapon
skins and yeah it's basically dying
lights take on a battle royale dying
like bad blood you get to PvE a little
bit with the zombies you know against
those guys that are near that some some
drops or cases that you can get guns
from yeah so if you want to check it out
cool yeah it's pretty fun time and you
know I probably look forward to playing
it a little bit more I did really like
dying light as a game looking forward to
dying light too of course
dying light is a kind of underrated game
and I think if you have time and you
want to go back and play kind of a fun
fast-paced like parkour zombie killing
crazy weapon crafting games should do it
it's got crazy fun Easter eggs if you
haven't seen some of them yeah it's a
fun time and until next time tomorrow
with Ben and John Luke for community
Fridays I'll see you next time thank you
so much don't forget hit that sub button
if you haven't talking to you guys peace
[Music]